la loi aujourd'hui en vigueur la loi
aujourd'hui en vigueur le mix
énergétique aujourd'hui en vigueur gravé
dans le marbre de la loi qui a été votée
il ya quatre ans par la majorité en
marche c'est on ferme 14 réacteurs
nucléaires les deux premiers ont été
fermés c'est fessenheim nous avertit les
républicains nous vous disons que c'est
une erreur qu'il faut préserver la
souveraineté énergétique de la france le
nucléaire est le meilleur moyen rancart
mais la base d'avoir quand même d'avoir
une énergie propre qui rejette le moins
de co2 parce que c'est la réalité c'est
que c'est l'énergie cre a fait le moins
de co2 même le panneau les panneaux
photovoltaïques rejette plus de co2 que
l'énergie nucléaire en termes de est-ce
que vous avez d'autres addictions avec
ce qui a été annoncé en février je ne
sont pas en contradiction les listes on
est tous
là seule je veux bien qu'on reconnaît
bien les chercher le match de manière on
est bien mais que le problème à y
rechercher les responsabilités c'est la
responsabilité du journaliste que vous
êtes et des médias et moi et moi
j'assume même si j'étais pas ce moment
la responsabilité ni dans la majorité ni
ailleurs ce qui a été fait par le
gouverneur ce mix énergétique que vous
avez fait voter par la majorité c'était
une erreur vous seriez pas dû le faire
voter je constate que les décisions
qu'il est ce que ces énergies et sans
épaisseur renverse que c'est une erreur
anvers et que c'est une erreur et vous
savez quand on fait des jeux bois dans
un sincère c'est que le précédent
n'était pas la politique des gouvernants
la politique ce gouvernement c'est
prévoir eux aussi le même emmanuelle
millet a changé son fils et le sommet
allait demeurer le même emmanuel macron
a vendu hadji aux américains les
turbines à gaz général a ajouté quelques
années plus tard deux fois le prix qui
les a vendus mais on est dans quel monde
on est dans un monde où il n'arrivait
vous n'arrivez pas vous majorité avoir
une vision claire sur le mode la réalité
si vous voulez avoir le vote des écolos
pour l'élection présidentielle vous avez
annoncé un truc totalement démago que
les fermer les centrales nucléaires
aujourd'hui on est dans cette situation
c'est aujourd'hui dans cette situation
on est à la merci de la divers possible
parce que c'est vous qui nous amène or
c'est faux